okay well I have decided to do the whole
show from now on with my crutches in the
shot the whole time and I figure it will
make me a more you know sympathetic
figure soften my image a little bit I'm
told that I'm you know I need to soften
it a little bit so I mean you you can't
send hate mail to a [ __ ] can you so
think about that whenever you're
whatever you're sitting down to write
your hate mail think about this okay I
think about the I'm on crutches you
monster my leg ow my leg the pain the
pain curse you paying need to work on
that a little bit I am usually a better
actor than that I'm sorry I'll just I
have to develop it so the point is
anyway the point is just feel sorry for
me because I am a victim all right okay
let's let's I want to start with a story
that is that is horrific
breathtaking shocking certainly
newsworthy
I would think yet it has been almost
completely ignored by the American media
liberal and conservative medium in in
fact the story broke on I think it was
Sunday or Monday and here we are on
Thursday and still I think most people
in America aren't aware of it have to
just simply have not heard of it because
almost no media outlet will touch it
it's been one of the most and I know
this is quite a statement but I would
say it's been one of the most
spectacular displays of collective
cowardice by our media in a long time
and that is saying something I realize
the story I'm referring to is about
Martin Luther King jr. a man who was
canonized even before his death and
certainly after his death has been given
the status of something that I think
goes beyond even st. to probably God
he's greater than a saint he is he's
more like an American god of sorts and
of course no no mortal being can live up
to that billing no human being can be a
deity or should be seen as a deity and
if reports if the recent reports about
luther king jr are true then that goes
especially for him uh now it's always
been known by those who care to pay
attention that MLK was a womanizer and
adulterer
so that that part really isn't new he
had many many affairs with with many
women probably fathered an illegitimate
child had orgies in hotel rooms and that
sort of thing that stuff we knew at
least informed people knew about that
and I suppose that those are the kinds
of flaws that though they are very
serious I mean these are very serious
moral failings if you are not faithful
to your wife are in fact serially
unfaithful to your wife then you have
failed as a man you know in in one of
the most fundamental ways you if you
have illegitimate children who you
didn't even accept as your own children
you failed as a father as well so you
failed is it failing as a husband and a
father it's pretty serious failings but
I think we we we generally accept those
kinds of failings in historical figures
and maybe for good reason because if we
start requiring that all of our great
historical figures also be chased and
and faithful to their spouses although
that's not that high of a bar to get
over if we started applying that bar
throughout history I think we would find
that we don't have very many people left
to honor at all which maybe wouldn't be
a bad thing but but I don't know there's
more to the story though with Martin
Luther King jr. it appears according to
a new report he wasn't just a womanizer
he wasn't just an adulterer he was also
a violent abuser and an enthusiastic and
approving witness of rape an accomplice
in rape perhaps even a rapist himself
depending on how we define our terms I
mean II think there are a lot of people
would say if you're an accomplice in
rape then you're a rapist so
let me read now from the Daily Mail and
I'm reading from the Daily Mail because
again the American media won't touch the
story with a ten-foot pole in fact if
you go right now to Google and try this
not right now but after the show go
Google Martin Luther King jr. click on
the news tab on Google and scroll down
and look at the the the outlets that are
that have stories about Martin Luther
King right now you're gonna find stories
in places like Business Insider Daily
Mail Christian Post The Independent
you're not going to see a CNN or NBC or
one of those guys so from the Daily Mail
just reading for the top of the article
says listening through headsets into the
bugged hotel suite next door the small
group of FBI agents couldn't quite
believe the sorted events that were
unfolding it was January 1964 and they
were hearing what sounded like a pastor
raping a female member of his
congregation
while his boss looked on laughing and
offering advice the voices of both men
were familiar according to the agents
sitting in the Willard hotel Washington
DC the rapist was an assistant to civil
rights leader Martin Luther King jr. and
his cohort or and his tour tling
companion was the anti racism icon
himself the man whose I have a dream
speech delivered a year earlier
continues to expire at inspire activists
to this day it goes on but Kings exalted
status could be about to unravel for
according to a Pulitzer prize-winning
biographer of King newly released FBI
files reveal that the binge-drinking
preacher had affairs with 40 to 45 women
indulged in hotel room orgies and even
fathered an illegitimate child the
documents also paint a violent picture
of king whose lust could soon turn to
anger in May 1965 for example one agent
reported that the civil rights leader
had gone to the home of one of his
female staff and torn her clothes off of
her and an apparent attempt to attack
her now this biographer is David Garrow
and he is not some crackpot he's a
Pulitzer prize-winning biographer of
Martin Luther King jr. he's a respected
literary figure and that's who this is
coming from more a little bit later on
the article it says according to
garrow's research the FBI planted
transmitters in two lamps in the Willard
hotel that King and
for himself and his friends in January
1964 when King arrived his close friend
Logan curse the pastor of a Baltimore
Baptist Church invited King and his
friends to meet women parishioners of
his church that he had brought to
Washington with him what followed was a
disturbing act of sexual violence the
group met in his room and discussed
which which women among the parishioners
would be suitable for natural or
unnatural acts said an FBI summary when
one of the women protested the Baptist
minister immediately enforce ibly raped
her it added King looked on laughed and
offered advice the following evening say
the file's King and his friends
participated in a sex orgy involving
twelve people at the hotel included acts
of degeneracy and depravity goes on from
there there was one woman who was didn't
want to participate she tried to shy
away from it but King pressured her and
and told her that it would help her soul
if she participated in the orgy some
more details like that details with
prostitutes and so on according to his
friend Ralph Abernathy King spent the
last night of his life with two lovers
followed by an encounter with a third
woman who be knocked sprawling across
his motel room bed after an argument and
there are more sordid details from there
but maybe you get the idea this is a man
who according to to this report is not
only a womanizer but not only an
adulterer but not only the father of an
illegitimate child but more importantly
someone who condoned and enjoyed
watching rape which in my opinion does
make him no different from a rapist
there's I don't see any distinction
really between a rapist and someone who
cheers on eggs on gives advice to a
rapist and watches well your rapist -
this is really no difference as someone
who abused women exploited them someone
who used his position as a pastor and
civil rights leader to prey on women
that's the picture painted now it'll be
said that
these stories are false that they were
made up by racist FBI agents to smear
MLK and it's true that that there were
plenty of people and law enforcement in
those days and the government in those
days who didn't like Martin Luther King
jr. because they were racist and they
didn't like his agenda of what was his
agendas agenda was civil rights right
Equal Rights so that's that's true and
you'd have to take that in consideration
but the problem with assuming that this
is all made up because of racism is well
there are a few problems number one
these stories are not all coming from
the FBI Kings own friends and
acquaintances give us some of these
details that bit about him you know
knocking a woman down the night before
his death in a fit of anger well that's
from his friend that's not from that's
uh that's that's that's not from from
FBI files the FBI files
unfortunately match up pretty well with
the picture that is painted of King by
people close to him so it's it it fits
in so it's not as though you've got
these FBI files and then everyone who
knew King says no it's not the man I
knew that's crazy that's he never would
have done anything like that that's not
what's happening here
second thing is this report comes from
as I said I respected and Pulitzer
prize-winning biographer of Martin
Luther King jr. not somebody with a
political agenda not a white nationalist
neo-nazi something like that
and number three Garrow accessed FBI
summaries of the tapes the tapes
themselves have been sealed until 2027
it's gonna be another eight years before
we get to hear these tapes ourselves but
the significance of that is if the tapes
are fabricated to smeared Martin Luther
King jr. then why would they be sealed
for 60 years you know you don't you know
if you're gonna if you're gonna make up
fake tapes to smear somebody you don't
file them away for a generation to make
sure that nobody hears them so it
doesn't make any sense the fact that
these things have been on their lock and
key and a bit of state secret for so
long that only lends credibility to them
because
why why else would we be locking these
tapes up if the tapes just contain
Martin Luther King being a great guy and
if there's a lot of great stuff in there
about what a wonderful duty was behind
the scenes then I think we would have
heard these tapes a long time ago like
fifty years ago 60 years ago but that's
not the case so while of course we can't
say for sure we can't say that we know
for sure just as we can't really know
anything for sure about any historical
figure I mean we can we're only we're
only dealing with degrees of probability
whenever we're talking about any detail
of any historical figures life because
most of us weren't there to see any of
it right so that's the case but it does
seem like these stories about King are
very credible and there is very good
reason to believe them unfortunately I
don't want to believe them why would I
want to and I don't think anybody wants
to but and I wouldn't want to believin
matter who he would he could have just
been some random Joe Schmo I wouldn't
want to but I don't want to believe this
kind of stuff about anybody who ever no
matter who they are because it's it's
it's horrible stuff but there is good
reason to believe them good factual
reason so then what then you know what
do we do with it
well I'll tell you what we don't do with
it
or what we shouldn't do with it we
shouldn't ignore it
we shouldn't bury it we shouldn't
pretend that it never happened we
shouldn't continue along worshiping the
man while plugging our ears so that none
of these details can interfere with our
devotional practices we shouldn't do
that and we shouldn't do that because
it's not honest it's cowardly it's wrong
it's just wrong
so do we go the other way do we rip down
his statues do we take his name off of
schools and streets and all of that I
mean Martin Luther King's name and
likeness and
statues and monuments are everywhere so
do we get rid of all that stuff well if
we're adopting a single standard if
we're adopting a single consistent
standard than yes then that's exactly
what we do if Thomas Jefferson if Thomas
Jefferson's murals have to come down if
Columbus statues have to come down if
robert e lee comes down if all of these
men get that treatment then why should
MLK be exempt there's just no good
reason to exempt him there just isn't
sure they're their sins are not the same
when we're talking about these other
guys I mentioned their sins are racial
they were racists who in some fashion
either condoned or participated in
slavery MLK wasn't that he was the
opposite of that when it comes to the
racial issue but are his sins really
better
I mean what's worse slavery or rape what
so so what's worse to condone and cheer
on slavery or to condone and cheer on
the rape I mean is that a discussion you
want to have because I don't do you
really want to get into ranking them and
having that argument say yeah well it's
a rape but it's not as bad as slavery I
would say that they are both hideously
evil eye.i I don't know if much more of
a moral distinction can be drawn between
them and so I think we just leave it at
that
they are hideously evil acts and so it
can be said of Thomas Jefferson and
Martin Luther King jr. that they both
condoned and participated in hideously
evil acts that involved the exploitation
dehumanization and violent abuse of
other human beings that's what we can
say about both of those men and if
that's the standard you know if if we
have the one standard and we're using
the standard that results in taking down
Martin Luther King statues and murals
then yeah
MLK's monuments have to come down and
his names have to come off the schools
there is another option okay the other
option is that we adopt one standard the
other way that we keep the MLK monuments
and we keep his names on the schools and
on the streets and we also keep the
Jefferson monuments and we keep the
Columbus monuments and we keep all of
the monuments and we start to develop a
mature intelligent nuanced
view of these men we stop idolizing them
because no man should be idolized we
stop worshipping them because no man
should be worshipped Matt MLK included
we don't ignore their flaws because no
man should have his moral failings
ignored we we allow criticism because
every man deserves criticisms for the
for the evil that he commits even if
he's dead that doesn't make it any
better if if MLK condoned and
participated in rapes and orgies and
things like that just because he's dead
that doesn't change the evil of those
acts and they still deserve to be
condemned but we also recognize the
greatness of their achievements and we
recognize that these are all men who did
things that we could not do and things
that had to be done things that change
the course of history
we recognize that we honor these men
because if they had never existed the
entire world would be different and
probably for the worst you know and
that's why we honor them
and if that's the standard that we're if
that's what we're doing now then yeah we
then this this information about MLK it
doesn't he doesn't change anything with
respect to his monuments and all that
stuff but it also can't change anything
with it with these other monuments
either and I think that's the way it's
got to be you know in my opinion that
third option is the way to go where
maybe we just we start being honest and
and we develop as I said a nuanced view
of these historical figures which I
think allows us to learn a lot more
about history and a lot more from
history and it just makes the historical
pursuit a lot more fruitful when you're
not worried anymore this is this is one
thing that I've realized that why
because because you know I enjoy reading
about history but very often when we
pick up a book of history no matter who
it's about or whatever historical period
it's about we go into it with
preconceived notions we go into it with
bias biases we go into it with a sort of
a narrative in mind that we're trying to
support and I think we all do that very
often when it comes to historical
subjects what I found is it's just it's
a lot more fruitful it's a lot more
interesting it's a lot more worthwhile
if you can manage to just put onto the
side and actually try to understand what
really happened and who these people
really were and to be willing to have
your childish notions about these people
destroyed and then replaced with not an
equally childish and simplistic notion
on the other side where they go from
gods to demons no not that but replaced
with a view of these people as human
beings as complicated human beings who
are capable of incredible
of courage but also incredible acts of
evil at the same time because that's
that's what it means to be human and I'm
okay with that I'm okay with looking at
history that way I'm just I'm not okay
with giving Martin Luther King jr. a
pass while not giving anyone else a pass
you just we can't do that I'm sorry I
admire what he did for the cause of
civil rights as much as anybody else but
if the man was an abuser and he condone
rape then that needs to be discussed and
that is something that is part of his
legacy
whether we like it or not and that's got
to be talked about in the schools when
the subject comes up in history that
stuff needs to be talked about that's
part of who he was apparently it was a
really significant part of who he was
all right um
let's stay with British media here for a
minute I was just giving them credit for
running the MLK story but now I have to
condemn them for for this it's the start
of the summer holidays and for this age
gap couple a chance to unwind love
camping because their peace and quiet
are mundi and I fall these happen and
I'm Beth and I'm 19
they're 28 year age gap may make them
look like father and daughter but they
are every bit a married couple
oh my dearly beloved he's going to set
up the doghouse when I get told off half
to go and live in a tent for a bit
Andy was originally a friend of Beth's
mum and over the years became close to
her children too we would all like one
happy family but needless to say I
didn't know that both through sight
getting these thoughts that she wanted
me to be a happy man for over sort of
thing you know but once she reached the
age of 16 Beth wanted to take their
friendship to the next level the age
doesn't really bother me in ever hass
tone I don't see him as an old man or my
dad or anything I can't it's just
sensitive tied together stop it I was
concerned what people think
16:40 it's a bit it's a bit big gap and
you know it's a generation gaps or
things suicide what people going to
think
however when Andy realised Betts was
serious he decided to give this
controversial relationship ago oh my
days I'd like to leave it leave it leave
it leave it getting all their eiated
with you today it all stressed just tell
me and once they'd fallen in love and he
became determined to give Beth
everything she had ever wanted
Edward oh this is Timmy he's - and this
is Conway and he's one I've always
wanted to make a family or to have a
family
so I just thought under it'd be the
perfect one to do so that's a show
called age gap love on channel 5 as you
could see there they give us the sort of
whimsical heartwarming story of a 45
year old man who began dating in quotes
a 16 year old girl who he'd known since
childhood Channel five calls this age
gap love another name for it is grooming
and abuse the girl was groomed by a
predator and then
was abused that's actually what happened
there now she's 19 today he's so he's
what 47 now if he as a 47 year old had
just met a 19 year old like they just
met online or something and then they
decided to get together now that would
be weird in my the really big age gaps I
do find them weird really no matter who
the people are but it's it's it's it's
it wouldn't be criminal or evil or
anything like that a 19 year old adult
woman is free to date 47 year old men if
she wants to but that's not what
happened here
see that's the important point what
happened here is that according to that
story he groomed a young girl over the
course of her childhood he was a friend
of her mother knew her as a child and
then made his move when she was 16 and
he was 44 so that's a completely
different situation if you don't think
that there's a movement to normalize
pedophilia in our society then think
again because that's what this is right
here now yeah this isn't technically
pedophilia technically pedophilia is the
abuse by an adult of a child who I think
is under has to be under 12 urgently
that's the legal definition of
pedophilia but this is a story of an
adult grooming abusing a child
regardless and as such it is the
normalization of pedophilia
normalization always happens this way
that's what this is what normalization
is okay so it's if there's going to be a
process a movement of normalizing
pedophilia it's not gonna start with
someone presenting us a story of a 45
year old man with his 9 year old child
bride and saying hey this isn't this
great let's cheer this on it's not gonna
start that way because that's too far
too fast
everybody will recoil from it so it's
the old boiling a frog and the pot type
of thing it's always going to start want
you to start on a lower temperature it's
gradual so it's always gonna start with
things that you know it starts with
something that is where you see it and
you go okay that's weird that's gross
it's not against the law I guess and
then gradually it gets more and more
depraved but the whole trick here among
the normalizer 's
is when they start with that first thing
where you're like as normal ever it's a
you know it's gross it's it's weird you
know it's a they start with that and if
they can kind of get you to say well who
are you to call that gross and then kind
of work on you there and if they can get
you to say okay yeah maybe that's fine
then you move on to the next thing and
your first reaction is oh no way and
they work on you there and try to get
you to say okay yeah maybe that's fine
and then just you gradually go down the
slope what that story you saw there it's
not at the beginning of the slope this
is like we're Midway slope right we're
about midway to full-on pedophilia is
okay type of thing we're about midway to
that point in our society the you know
drag the drag queens story hours these
these child drag queens that you see
that's that's also about midway to the
slide so probably I know it's actually
much further down it's much closer to
the full on normalization of pedophilia
so that's that's what's that's what's
happening all right before we get to
emails I let's see here okay I have a
question before we get to I just want to
mention one thing you know I I said at
the top that I am a victim as you can
see so you should feel sorry for me
because I'm crippled but here's the
question that I've been wondering maybe
you can help me out with this and you
can always email me to let me know what
you think Matt well show at gmail.com my
question is how many victim points do I
actually acquire for being crippled and
so it's it's kind of a complicated
subject because obviously I start in a
hole because I'm a straight white male
so the way I figure the math is kind of
like this being white means that I'm at
negative 25 victimhood points male means
another another negative 25 and then
straight is another negative 25 so I'm
at I'm in a woman about a 75
point hold just just to begin with
because I'm a straight white male but
I'm disabled them so that earns me back
I would say 25 yet you would point out
that my disability is probably temporary
so that detracts 10 meaning um only at
plus 15 against minus 75 right so that
puts me at minus 60 yet if my Achilles
heels wrong or if I get surgery and
something goes wrong with the surgery
there is a possibility that I might not
ever walk normally again
now that would be I think worth 25 on
top of the plus 15 so I'm at plus 40
against negative 75 which works out to
about negative 35 right but wait I'm
also part negative Native American I'm
part Native American on my mom's side I
think maybe actually I just made that up
but it's I mean there's a there's a
there's a great there's a possibility
that I'm part Native American so let's
just say that I am you can't prove that
I'm not so that's got to be worth
something and I'm also definitely part
Irish and I know being Irish isn't worth
much even though the Irish are among the
most persecuted people on the planet
historically they're also white so it
doesn't count for much but I think it
all adds up to maybe I mean that's gotta
be worth another plus five I mean it's
got to be five victim points there right
that combination the fact that I might
be part Native American and I am
definitely part Irish
I think I'm part all stray lien yeah
that doesn't really count at all but
that's got to be worth at least five so
I think it all adds up to maybe let's
say plus forty five against minus
seventy five which equals negative 30 so
I'm still not at victimhood status but
I'm doing better than a lot of you I am
closer to victimhood status than most of
you straight white Devils that's my
point that I'm trying to make and so you
need to acknowledge that and have some
deference for that it's all I'm saying
okay let's let's check in with emails
Matt wall show at gmail.com Matt wall
show at gmail.com this is from Sara says
hi Matt I know you have lived and
visited various places on the East Coast
our young family of six is headed out
that way later this summer for the first
time we love learning about the area as
we visit and doing things that aren't
typically touristy types of activities
but are more hidden gems or local
favorites that being said we also have
for kids ages ranging from three to
twelve years old
we don't know we don't want to bore them
to death in museums all day do you have
any recommendations of places to visit
in the DC Maryland Delaware Virginia
Beach region that would be good for kids
of various ages also any family-friendly
restaurant school ice cream shops
anything else unique or interesting to
see hi Sara well that's that I
appreciate the question it's kind of a
large area it's like hundreds of miles
so I would need to know more
specifically where you're going to be
like you need to give me your exact
street address so that I can answer that
and publish it everywhere no I just if I
knew more specifically where you're
gonna be I could probably help you out
more I will say if you're going to be on
the Eastern Shore Ocean City is kind of
the spot there now that's very touristy
but that's in terms of Eastern Shore you
want to go to the beach a lot of stuff
for kids to do there if you're looking
for a less touristy Eastern Shore Beach
spot then maybe Bethany Beach a little
bit further up north again I don't know
where you're gonna be feeling for
something more historical in the
Virginia area then you could always
check out Mount Vernon or Monticello
speaking of a Thomas Jefferson
there are now if this is your first time
on the East Coast and if you like
history then I think you got to check
out at least a couple the Civil War
battlefields because you know the
eastern theater of the of the Civil War
if you're going to be in Virginia then I
think you got to go a Virginia Maryland
area you got to go check out some of
those but again it depends on where
specifically they're gonna be if you're
a little bit further west than maybe
Antietam I went there with my wife last
year and that was a great a great stop
of course up further north into
Pennsylvania
you could go to Gettysburg
if you are further west and you want
scenic views and nature and everything I
would go in the Shenandoah Valley is
beautiful
the Luray Caverns Annapolis is a nice
little city of Maryland the capital
Marin nice historical city if you are in
DC then definitely take your kids to the
Bible Museum I know you said no museums
but check out the Bible Museum the
Museum of Natural History I mean look it
yeah it if you've never been to the
museums in DC they are great museums and
Baltimore has for my money and I say
this as I'm a big aquarium fan I love
aquariums and I've been to many
aquariums in my day Baltimore has the
best aquarium certainly in the country
and I don't think I'm the only one with
that opinion so I would go there if
you're around that spot and if you're in
Delaware there is a nice ice cream spot
in Lewis town called Lewes Delaware
there's a dairy farm that does its own
ice cream but that's kind of far from DC
so it all depends on where you're gonna
be but have a great trip from Chuck he
says hey Matt you recently talked about
how the word nazi' now means anyone who
has a political opinion I disagree with
I think this development is a symptom of
a broader problem our society has lost
any notion of gradations I see this in
our societies excessive swearing as well
as the desire to live a life of
highlights on social media everything is
either zero or a hundred with no levels
in between I was wondering what your
take was on this do you see something
similar or am i over generalizing I love
the show and I pray that you don't
become discouraged with the hateful
messages you receive yeah I totally
agree and I think that this kind of
plays into what we talked about during
the show about historical figures and
how we need to develop more nuanced
views of these historical figures I
think we need to develop more nuanced
views in general about everything and
that would certainly make our
discussions our conversations much more
worthwhile and fruitful because right
now it's it's just hard to talk about
anything because everybody is exactly
what you're talking about
everyone is you're either for or against
it's either great or it's terrible
uh and there's just there's no room in
between and that's the case even though
at the same time everyone likes to say
all the time how well it's it's it's
it's not black and white there's a lot
of gray area so we like to talk about
gray areas but then and we like to try
to find gray areas in places where there
actually isn't any gray area because
sometimes it is just wrong or right
right but then when it comes to most
conversations no people don't want gray
areas they want everything to be very
clear which is especially frustrating I
could tell you for for me as a writer
when I try to write a piece and I'm
dealing with a controversial subject and
I write a thousand words about it trying
in great detail to explain my
perspective well nobody wants to read it
they what they want is give me the one
sentence summary of your point of view
and but it's just not every point of
view can be summarized in a sentence
sometimes it takes 50 sentences
sometimes it takes more than one
sentence sometimes but people don't want
that a lot of it comes down to
intellectual laziness and anyway that's
I agree with you that's a good point
this is from Riley says you mentioned
your recent injury on your show so I
just wish to let you know I'll be
praying for a speedy recovery for you I
will admit however that I'm disappointed
that the story to go with it wasn't very
cool stay strong thanks for being a
great brother in Christ respectfully
Riley Riley I agree that it's not a cool
story I'm disappointed in that I always
imagined that when eventually I ended up
in an emergency room for my own issue it
would be for a really awesome reason and
that was just not the case you know I
always imagined like my first time in
the emergency room it would be because I
was fighting off armed invaders maybe
with a sword or something I always
thought it'd be something like that but
instead it was just a pickup basketball
game and that is just a tragedy this is
from John says hey Matt it's John big
fan of the show each episode is a sigh
of relief from this crazy world that
said I wanted to get your opinion
on the Hitchens razor that which can be
asserted with that without evidence can
be dismissed without evidence it's
Christopher Hitchens obviously the
reason that I bring this up is because I
found it as a very powerful tool to
combating the left due to so many of
their claims being completely baseless
specifically I've utilized it in
combating the pro-choice argument since
the Alabama ban that no uterus no
opinion has been kicked into high gear
this has been my argument most commonly
we have agreed that it is not acceptable
to kill an innocent human being so
implicit in your argument for abortion
is the premise that the unborn fetus is
not a life but simply I don't believe
you
the burden of proof is on you to prove
your assertion to put it on me is to
shift the burden of proof which is a
logical fallacy so far I am most
commonly attacked for finding God or
upholding the patriarchy to which I
reply first I come from women's
abortions rights then will be their
suffrage winky-face
sarcasm I know this is a long email I
thank you for getting to it if you do I
really want to know any flaws in this
argument and if there is any way I can
improve it yeah I think the Christopher
hitch the Hitchens razor is interesting
because obviously that's something he
formulated mainly as an attack on
theists and what he's claiming is that
well you are proposing the existence of
God without evidence and so I can just
dismiss it without evidence now I
disagree with Hitchens razor in that
case because I think that there is
evidence for God so we're not proposing
it without evidence but I agree in
general in principle with the principle
that if someone does propose something
without evidence then yeah it can be
dismissed without evidence because if
you are making an assertion any
assertion if you're coming to the table
proposing something for people to
believe as true whatever it is then you
have to be able to give people a reason
to believe it and the reason can't just
be that you said it because that's not a
reason the fact that it was said is not
in itself a reason to believe that there
has to be some other reason if you can't
produce that reason or explain what it
is then yeah everyone at the table can
just say whatever and they they're
perfectly within their rights to do that
and it's rational to do it because you
haven't given them any reason to believe
it and so can that'll be applied to the
abortion argument sure I think it can be
because I would say that
the people claiming that the unborn
child is not a person is not a human
have produced no evidence to support
that assertion in fact all the evidence
is against them we have a lot of
evidence to bring to bear to prove that
it is open up any biology textbook about
you know the stages of human development
and what you're going to find is that
the fetal stage is a stage of human
development because it's a human so they
have no evidence which means that right
their argument can't be taken seriously
so sure this is for mics as the first
time you mentioned becoming a beekeeper
I couldn't help think about how
dangerous it is to have a beehive around
three small children I'm sure you've
carefully weighed the risks and made
sure the hive is in a safe and secure
location but as a parent does it ever
cross your mind it's something you can
go seriously wrong that ends up with one
of your kids getting hurt how do the
logistics of this beehive setup work
that that ensure your family safety also
who will tend to the beekeeping duties
now that you're on crutches yeah Mike
it's it's keep bee hives are very safe
actually because the honey bees as
opposed to say wasps or something honey
bees are docile creatures they're not
aggressive they're not going to go after
you and attack you they're not they're
not really interested in what you're
doing they're just interested in tending
to the hive so they'll go right around
you and I mean I mean you can open up a
beehive and some of the bees will come
out to check see what's going on but
most of that bees will just continue on
their business
you could they're not going to come
after you I don't recommend opening up a
bee hive if you don't have a bee suit
but so it's it's it's really not a
danger at all of course we've told our
kid we they know where the hive is I've
taken them out I've shown him to him
I've they've come out when I've and
stood at a safe distance when I've been
when I've opened up the hive just to see
everything and so you know you just you
teach the kids it's like anything else
it's like the chemicals that are under
your sink you know you teach them don't
open under the sink and you just have to
knowledge his power the situation as far
as who will tend to the hive now that
I'm on crutches that's a good question
I'm thinking that my six-year-old son
is ready to take the dive I don't have a
beast suit that will fit him so he's
gonna have to really go for it but like
I said safety first finally from a
different mic says if a president
committed a crime the proper procedure
would be to impeach him then charge him
with the crime so no president is above
the law it's just a different process
and one that I agree with imagine that
Trump could be charged with a crime
there's no doubt the Democrats will be
charging him with jaywalking littering
disturbing the peace anything they could
just to make him spend his whole term in
court fighting bogus charges
therefore the president is not above the
law it's just a different process meant
to curtail frivolous prosecution you
don't have to be guilty to be charged
with anything thank you for agreeing
with me in advance and have a nice day
Mike I yeah I said yesterday I think
that president should be able to be
charged with a crime but you raised a
good point and so I think that I was
wrong and that you are right doesn't
happen very often so enjoy the moment
savor it
but yeah I think I was I was wrong about
that one and I will change my point of
view I hope you're proud of yourself
though for humiliating me a [ __ ] a
man on crutches and you would dare
humiliate me like this in front of my
entire audience outrageous but thanks
for the email and thanks everybody for
watching Godspeed today on the Ben
Shapiro show Robert Muller issues his
farewell address and Democrats move
toward impeachment that's today on the
bench Shapiro show